I think the a turning point was when
fouy admitted the six foot distance was
invented out of whole cloth it was
invented from and and I knew that two
years ago by talking to all these
cancelled doctors and I talked to a guy
named Paul Alexander two years ago who
was in the room when uh Redfield is that
was name made the decision he goes why
why 6 feet there's an aerosolized virus
it be 30 to 60 feet certainly 10 feet
and they actually agreed on maybe 10
feet they took 10t to the off the white
house and some political operative said
well no one will ever agree to that just
say 6 feet for and so it was never a
medical decision it was no scientific
basis to it whatsoever it's had no
utility and yet I mean think about this
the whole world adopted it the entire
world that to me is the really
astonishing part about that experience
of covid that lockdown was adopted by
the world six feet was adopted by the
world masks were adopted by the world
with none of it
being considered for risk reward
analysis like what might happen as a
result of this and it was obvious to me
there was going to be horrible mental
health consequence was obvious yeah I
want to get to that obvious uh or is
there any medical data to support this
you were crushed if you tried to have
that conversation that's going to start
to come to light for
people how how much we've talked about
this a little bit before but how much
much did your political Evolution shift
because of the covid craziness because
when I had you on last time in studio
was still in La so it's about over two
and a half years ago you were still sort
of saying some nice things about fouchy
and I know you guys have a history I
sense you've shifted a bit on that or at
least you're amable to some other ideas
I am I am open to everything now I'm
open to things that I never thought I
would have been open to and I I really
think that the door fully th came open
I I I've realized that everything in the
in the news is BS everything there there
is nothing that I can consume on any
Legacy Media that I can trust and that
is shocking and that's disturbing and it
makes you wonder how long it's been
going on for and I'm concerned it might
have been a very long time yeah was
there a straw that broke the camels back
on that specifically yes I was going to
tell you that my my interview with RF my
first interview with RFK Jr he was so
reasonable so smart and so many
interesting ideas and enlightened me to
this cozy relationship between the
regulators and the Pharma companies
which I really wasn't aware of I me I
can't let a Pharma company
representative into my office to give me
a pen with a drug name name on it and
yet those guys are living together and
cross-pollinating J I mean that's
mindboggling to me so and that he had a
very sensible didn't necessarily fully
agree with it but a sensible idea about
vaccine research that he would like to
push forward not that vaccines are bad
his family's all vaccinated my family's
all vaccinated and at the end of that
interview he said something to me I've
met him now many times since then he
goes oh my good you know Drew you are so
courageous to talk to me and I and I
thought it blew me back in my chair I
thought I need courage to have a
conversation with an adult in a public
setting and he was right this is this is
a time where I didn't realize how much
speech was being suppressed uh how much
was being manipulated how much then what
happened after that was the Twitter
files and they started seeing what was
going on and it just it's just been to
me this is all
reprehensible and what has happened as a
result I don't think I've shifted my
political views I've just really in the
I never imagined I'd be this point in my
life at this age and place in my career
freedom and freedom fighting and the
courage of stand up for it have been the
most important thing in my life right
now and that's crazy that is CRA I live
in the United States of America and I
have to worry about freedoms I'm to
fight for Freedom that is an insanity
and I'm hoping it's something that will
pass soon yeah well you know there's a
far less chance they're going to put you
in a goog in the Free State of Florida
rather than the commun come to Florida
to florid of California all right I've
sold Florida what do you think
psychologically this is one of the
things I talk about on the show a lot
that that basically psychologically now
if you are somebody that watches
corporate press and pretty much think
that is true and then you're someone
that maybe watches this or Rogan or you
or just that mix people RFK in there too
of course that your worlds are so
different now that psychologically as a
nation how do we put that together like
you could literally be basically living
in a completely different world than
your neighbor we that is what we are
doing that's what's happening right now
and it it's actually makes me sad
because it prevents any kind of
discourse and conversation people get I
can feel their stomach muscles
tightening up when I just try to have a
conversation and that's that's so
disturbing to me I I I guess
I think what's going to
happen I think
enough uh sort of slowly uncovering of
how much distortions have gone on and
how arbitrary and capricious and and and
dangerous and horrible consequences
these decisions have had it's going to
come to light I don't know if it's going
to be that there really are excess
deaths I'm worried that there are if
there are that's going to keep happening
and we're going to see something I don't
know it's co I don't know if it's covid
plus vaccine but these conversations
will evolve with time and eventually I
think people will start to go oh I'm
starting to see a bigger picture I think
the I think the a turning point was when
foui admitted the six foot distance was
invented out of whole cloth it was
invented from and and I knew that two
years ago by talking to all these
canceled doctors and I talked to a guy
named Paul Alexander two years ago who
was in the room when uh Redfield was
made the decision he goes why why 6t
there an aerosolized virus it be 30 to
60 ft certainly 10t and actually agreed
on maybe 10 feet they took 10 feet to
the off the White House and some
political operative said well no one
will ever agree to that just say six
feet for and so it was never a medical
decision it was no scientific basis to
it whatsoever it's had no utility and
yet I mean think about this St the whole
world adopted it the entire world that
to me is the really astonishing part
about that experience of covid that
lockdown was adopted by the world six
feet was adopted by the world masks were
adopted by the world with none of it
being considered for risk reward
analysis like what might happen as a
result of this and it was obvious to me
there was going to be horrible mental
health consequence it was obvious yeah I
want to get to that obvious uh or is
there any medical data to support this
you were crushed if you tried to have
that conversation that's going to start
to come to light for people do you think
there will ever be any Reckoning
whatsoever I mean basically everyone who
got us into this either still has their
job or have retired with with cushy
retirements or and or made hundreds of
thousands if not millions of dollars in
stocks on these things I mean is there
any Reckoning
anywhere I hope at at minimum
particularly young people become Furious
they should be outraged and angry at
what was done to them if that happens I
think personally I think that's enough
now I know there's a lot of people that
want retribution all kinds of legal
action and civil or criminal I I really
worry about that I I I'm telling you uh
the present moment I become obsessed
with revolutionary France obsessed and I
wanted to put a chapter in my book on
narcissism on pre-revolutionary France
because it was the only period of
History they could find which as with as
much narcissism and childhood trauma and
one of my one of my con conclusions that
I wanted to put in that chapter which my
editor told me was too speculative was
that there would be scapegoating there
would be Guillotines that's what
guillotin is just scape just massive
scapegoating and never heard of
cancellation but here it came so
scapegoating became this social media
phenomenon that I
predicted um why did I bring this up um
so the the problem is that if you if you
pull people up on the guillotine The
Guillotines just kept keep going and
eventually everybody go it's a
mathematical certainty of skateboarding
eventually everybody first it was the
jacoban then it was the sankula and then
it was the royalist everybody goes on
the guillotina if you somebody doesn't
say stop so so what at the all right so
if that's not possible or not realistic
or you're sort of afraid of what the end
and by the way the other part is you'll
never get to the truth right because
people will be so defensive and scared
they're not going to come forward with
what actually happened I'm I want the
truth out that's the most important
thing so would the bigger problem then
be that the pharmaceutical companies
seemingly have done none of that
internal research or investigation or
anything right like as far as I can tell
they're still into all of this and wef
is talking about disease X and and the
rest of it like that it all just kind of
come around again well that's the great
that's the great risk right I I don't
think people will put up for it I think
that there's enough outrage I think they
will oh my God that I I if they I think
they would just say no this is the real
one we we did screw up on Co and a lot
of it was wrong but this one it's 10
times worse and they're going to show
you a video from China some guy wigg out
on the floor and I think people would do
it
again I'm actually maybe not in certain
places I'm actually more concerned that
they do need to social distance in some
meaningful way and we don't because we
don't believe them I I think that's
possible too yeah I I think that's a
higher probability and probably better
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell